[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we'll be discussing Horcruxes and how
they're destroyed if you don't know what
a Horcrux is already well shame on you
but for the sake of the video will
briefly introduce the subject anyway the
Horcrux is an object in which a dark
witch or wizard has imbued part of their
soul the purpose of doing this is to
make it difficult for the witch or
wizard to be completely killed achieving
immortality in a sense in order to
create a Horcrux you must commit murder
and the rest of the process is up to
interpretation I'll make a video on how
a Horcrux is made further down the line
Voldemort infamously used Horcruxes to
keep himself alive so now that that's
out of the way how are they destroyed
commonly Horcruxes are protected with
counter charms and jinxes this can make
it difficult to even approach them but
if you are fortunate enough to
circumvent these jinxes and counter
charms what's your next move
how can you destroy them there are some
commonly accepted ways for how this is
achieved but also some that are never
revealed by the films in the Deathly
Hallows book there is an excerpt which
vaguely suggests that there are a number
of ways to destroy them perhaps ways
that we don't know about and once we get
a hold of it how do you destroy a
Horcrux Ron asked Hermione
well said Hermione I've been researching
that how in the name of Merlin's pants
have you managed to get your hands on
those Horcrux books said Ron throughout
their conversation mind it's saying they
them and books which to me suggests that
there are perhaps more ways to destroy
Horcruxes than the ones we know about
either that or the books are just out
learning the exact ways that we already
know throughout the books and films
there are various destruction methods
definitively demonstrated let's run
through them basilisk fangs and basilisk
venom in the books and films the fabled
basilisk Fang is used to destroy a
couple of Voldemort's Horcruxes
including hufflepuff's cup and Tom
Riddle's diary this is because the
basilisk Fang contains basilisk venom
the true destructive agent that's
capable of taking down a horrid
at one point Harry uses Godric
Gryffindor sword to cut the roof of the
basilisks mouth imbuing the sword with
basilisk venom it was for this reason
that Harry was able to use this same
sword to destroy my Fuhrer Gaunt's ring
and Salazar Slytherin's locket fiend
fire fiend fire is a form of advanced
dark magic a curse that produces
enchanted flames of immense size and
heat fiend fire destroys anyone and
anything in its path and it assumes the
form of gigantic fiery beasts like
serpents chimeras and Dragons when I say
that fiend fire can destroy anything I
mean anything fiend fire is responsible
for destroying Rowena Ravenclaw's diadem
in the Room of Requirement inside of
Hogwarts the diadem was kicked into
instant crabs unintentional fiend fire
the killing curse Avada Kedavra aka the
killing curse and one of the
unforgivable curses was used by
Voldemort to destroy the Horcrux inside
of Harry however the destruction of the
Horcrux is achieved one thing is
massively important and that is that the
Horcrux is beyond magical reconstitution
it isn't possible to magically fix
certain types of damage and it just so
happens the damage from basilisk venom
fiend fire and Avada Kedavra fit this
criteria when Harry was bitten by the
basilisk in the Chamber of Secrets
people were confused as to why he didn't
die since he's Horcrux
JK Rowling publicly answered this
question and announced that because his
life was not beyond repair it would not
have been enough to destroy it
Harry would have needed to have died but
Forks tears were able to save him
remember it is the container that needs
to be destroyed beyond magical repair
and in this case Harry was the container
and that's all for this video they don't
miss any methods for how a Horcrux is
destroyed give any theories let me know
down in the comment section below until
next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]